okay hello everyone so this will be the
final session before our screening of
Canterbury tale after our second keynote
speaker today it is my pleasure and
honor to introduce today's keynote
speaker dr. David Allen Miller professor
Miller comes to us from the University
of Sussex in England where his professor
of history of art and also connected
with the university center for the
history of war and society and the
Sussex Center for the visual yet it
would be no exaggeration to say that his
lively activity in Britain and abroad as
a curator scholar has made it his artist
and period studies so influential dare i
say unavoidable for those of us who
study 20th century britain for more than
two and a half decades his insights into
20th and 21st century English art and
visual culture have led the way in
shaping our understanding of English art
photography and film encouraging us to
set aside biographical biases and myopic
formalism in favor of an animated
layered cultural history of the visual
in Britain having studied under Quentin
Bell one of his earliest feats was the
exhibition and accompanying catalogue to
the 1988 barbican exhibition a paradise
lost the neo-romantic visual imagination
in Britain which took the bold step of
situating Bacon's paintings alongside
Powell impress burgers film and verse
collected by d'afrique Grigson he
followed this with countless studies of
artists photographers and periods of
British artistic culture that weave
together connections across works in a
very disparate media I would point to
his volumes on Cecil Beaton parling
Botti Robin Denny and his reading of
course on Francis Bacon as my own
personal favorites his impact in the
area of British photographic history has
been especially formative including the
recording Britain exhibition of mass
observations photographic activities and
grappling with post-war Britain for so
many years his numerous books on the
1960s and dis artists remained essential
reading in particular the 60s arts Eden
in London
and the 60s Britain and France 1962 to
1973 the utopian years if I may he's
drawn his pen for the second world war
on multiple occasions as well in recent
years his text text with a wonderful
title and oh the stench Spain the Blitz
objection and shelter drawings for the
Tate's 2010 Henry Moore exhibit a
chapter devoted to the second world war
in the Kenneth Clark looking for culture
in 2014 and most recently he was
co-curator for the archive of modern
conflict room in time conflict and
photography at Tate Modern in short one
might characterize David as a weaver of
the cultural record with a
cross-disciplinary approach to histories
of visual Britain and indeed Britain's
vision of itself so please join me in
welcoming professor David Allen eller
wonderful can you hear me can you hear
me well I am profoundly embarrassed and
I can ardly say in a word after that
introduction and when Tim behringer
contacted me a little while ago to speak
I was delighted but I did think I wonder
if he really means visual culture
because folks visual couch is different
to the history of art to art history
it's a component of it but it's it it
was one of the ways in which when people
talked loosely about a new art history
in the 70s and 80s which did you
generated into culture wars between
theorists and you know that much of that
story they were barking up the wrong
tree the action was elsewhere it was to
do with
the opening up of the barriers the and
inclusiveness towards photography film
social contexts obviously what I'm going
to do will be bewildering for setting
the wildering to me and possibly to you
I I it's an overview I was asked to give
a how would you call these are ideal
what do you call this a keynote 2k night
so I've envied I've been instructed and
informed and envied those people who've
gone before me who had very intensive
tasks which have been which have been so
good so I've been saying for this this
you know if anybody rather like my
students at the end of this will say
well what was all that about okay let's
begin here so let me I mentioned Tim I
wanted also to thank Sophie the inferred
for for her excellent framework of
support and organization and obviously i
am thrilled to be a yale to do this one
last word I'd like to dedicate this to
the memory of my father who served in
the Royal Artillery and in the British
Expeditionary Force in nineteen forty
and forties way back to be evacuated at
bellowing much of my interest in the 40s
is to do with a continued immersion
during childhood and inert and
adolescents in this it's never gone away
okay so let's begin this is um this is
sergeant john Pfeiffer and this is a
document from an album that he put
together of his experiences in England
in the month or two before d-day
and he was Sergeant a he ran a motor
pool with the infantry and he he took
photographs of they moved around as they
got to the jumping off point a new haven
and he photographed things that intrigue
him and he had a particular Sensibility
he was from west new york and what
attracted him were if you like things
that we associate with Ripley's Believe
it or not it's it's and he wrote on the
back of this picture so it's in English
is a cottage six you know 16th century
cottage so this is an encounter this is
an encounter with British culture by an
American and I'm interested very often
there's this crosscut I'm interested in
the crosscurrents Americans in England
and English people like Roald Dahl who
was an intelligence officer seconded to
Washington who worked with Walt Disney
and we'll be looking at that so these
these cross currents which are very
important so he's seeing what recording
Britain is seeing except the Greek all
in Britain are taking our representing
it like this in our in a serious English
topographic picturesque watercolor
tradition I'll be thinking mainly about
certain themes and i'll be picking some
of those out let me let me let me list a
few of them just so you know what's
coming up on the menu here RAF pilots
and this is a particularly important RFP
that I'll explain that later sitting in
poppy fields rickety children rickety
bye meanie rickets rickety I mean
rickets the that particular disease
which stunted poor children's growth
vulnerable blit monarchs who have been
rrible and they've been blitzed
long-haired dissident painters barely
out of their team's posturing and
finding themselves as in the new culture
of swing music in in London we mentioned
jazz the importance of that for
Sylvester and it's something I pull it
out pull in at the end to it in the
sidelines so I'd like with your approval
to help show how these iconography and
some actual situations constructed a
series of jostling narratives about
British exceptionality during the war
because that it's the pit can't piss
picturesque and pick a risk that
attracts sergeant Pfeifer as he makes
his way to battle in in Normandy this is
about British exceptionality I suppose
so these were were coping strategies
many of them in which individuals at the
time found ways of making things legible
under a condition of terror terms of
day-to-day life survival through
turbulent years our touch on ways in
which we've heard very detailed thick
micro studies of this in which
government bodies and ministries
commissioned and shaped the visual
imagination of the time and how they did
so through the guiding agencies of
specific individuals obvious again
o'clock but also Monroe wheeler at mama
so you'll be hearing illustrious names
but also people you may not have heard
of like Captain Abram games there was
official poster designer to the War
Office so let me just list the topics
will move through I think comedy is very
important that's why I wanted to begin
with with sergeant 54 laughing with with
his members of his platoon so comedy and
then I did mention I want to think about
the monarch about Georgia 6 very
important figure in an imperial context
and then to touch on questions of points
of view of vantage points and imaginary
spaces and notions of lyrical freedom
that extend as far as see Kenneth Clark
endorsing the idea that English weather
is the precondition of English art I
want to think about the Blitz a little
bit and i'll mention something we saw
before and that is the Monroe wheeler
Kenneth Clark collaboration Britain at
war at mama in 1941 I think about pilots
and also since Tim said you will talk
about neo romanticism won't you and and
I'll touch on Omni romanticism as well
and then end up with delinquency and the
way in which for people like Paxton and
Freud American culture means another
model of behavior
when the mode of the music changes then
the whole culture changes to UM so back
to sergeant Pfeiffer forgive me if I
read parts of this and it sounds stilted
I'm sorry so he notices things like this
a hedge cut in the shape he thinks of a
teapot I'm not sure I'm not sure what it
is but and I mentioned that believe it
or not aspect of this the other thing
that struck me when I came across this
cache of material this album in the
archive of modern conflict in London was
how far it actually reflected something
he may not have realized about English
graphic culture visual culture and that
is the way in which people like Piper
Michelle guides to England had
encouraged this this comic view of of an
English landscape full of exceptional
weird things so you know poor Nash is
not alone in in this this is a in
Cardiff Wales he writes on the bag and
it's things like this of course here's
another teapot but Julian Trevelyan
spotted on the promenade Blackpool so
these are part of a rather strange comic
thread that moves through this ok this
is the worst jpg you've ever seen in
your life and I do apologize for that I
I had to steal it from the punch website
I don't know how much you can make out
this is roland emic the artist is
rowlandm it who is an English comic he
was a cartoonist and what's occurring in
this is that we've got an an extremely
gothic picturesque English tea shop
and one of the assistants has gone out
to this schematic Sherman tank and has
taken an order and she's you know I'm
sorry the captions not in line that you
can't see it but she's then reporting
back to the lady who runs a tea shop and
she says they wonder if we can do 46
cream teas and and I so again English
exceptionality meet and eccentricity
meets the Sherman tank in a kite in in a
drawing like this Clark is quite close
to Niklaus pevsner at this point and he
Clark impaired a dream up this idea of
drawing together pub and in signs and
making an exhibition and also a penguin
book about them so here's one of them
and Clark rights to any number of
contacts who are in provincial art
schools across England and now you know
the key for those of you who may know
the BBC television series blackadder the
the key to English culture can be found
in the characters certainly English
class culture but you find there and the
if you like that hobbledehoy wretched
figure of Baldrick is is I always find
enlightening for coming to an
understanding of the way stanley spencer
is presented and this is picture pose
presenting this crazy loon who is an
official war artist stammering splitting
and all of these things and then
alongside Baldrick of course is is
captain blackadder and the idea of the
representatives of the male
representative of the english ruling
classes
being in some way cads or rogues and I
just include this it's a photograph
taken by Steven spend of the poet's
brother Humphrey spender who worked as
an official photographer during the war
and this man is lord lovat and over his
shoulder he's got on up over his
shoulder mother standard-issue english
rifle he's leaving number for commander
and the commander has just returned from
the Dieppe raid which was a bloodbath
and what he's got is again English
exceptionality he's carrying a
Winchester rifle over his shoulder and
lovins of it's extremely fascinating
again the and I shouldn't say English
because of course he is something like
twenty fourth Baron lord lovat so so of
Scotland now the other thing to bear in
mind here is populists imagery when the
first exhibition of English wall art was
shown at the national gallery we heard a
bit of a plantation gallery the Ulster
secretary to whack to the war artists
Advisory Committee a man called a mor
Dickey wrote to Clark saying look you've
got a lot of I'm paraphrasing a lot of
not very good topographical drawings and
paintings but if you look at Eric
Penningtons drawings of seamen who just
come back from the Narvik raid and
whatever they blow them off the wall
because this is this the these are
compelling pictures and they are
compelling propaganda that's what he
says so this is able seaman Povey i'll
come back to jenison later now you know
it's an imperial culture and
I'm sorry we should have him I like to
you know that's okay what I found so
extraordinary about Cassius Clay's talk
was the way in which a certain Imperial
bureaucracy I was going to almost a tech
nos Kristen technocracy but it's it's a
particular form of administrative
organization the way in which that
acquires classical literally a classical
representation you know kalica gothy at
the the greek word and he would have
known though he's a man of plain words
he would have known that and around in
that imperial schema things at the
center is this shy diffident monarch and
and that was so interesting about the
king's speech was that it gave this
impression of this diode absolute didn't
want the job was impeded in various ways
and yet becomes the most beloved of
recent monarchs and is still referred to
by people of a certain ages the old king
there's a wonderful short story by jg
ballard in which he imagines an
alternative Britain he wrote it in the
weight of the siege of QA in 1968 and
ballad imagines that in an alternative
Britain the district of Windsor the of
the Imperial center of Windsor rather
than hue is a contested ground between
English guerilla forces and American
marines and one little details very
telling as a marine's of fighting their
way through house to house as they did
at UA they find on the floor a picture
of George the six
smashed out of its frame that he is that
here is the up is a memory from the
future of the nobility of this of this
man sorry it's my I don't know how to
turn this bloody thing off I over-wound
I overwhelmed by isn't this interesting
I dedicated this to my father because I
over-wound by father's old Swiss watch
wristwatch and and I broke the bloody
spring so I had to buy a I went back to
the 1980s and bought myself a Casio
watched which I can't control I I simply
anyway he's latter days often ii picture
of the monarch and his family and the
key thing is that in a very important
symbolic event Buckingham Palace's bond
during the during the Blitz daylight
spin that's when the luftwaffe of
fighting it in daylight they
opportunistically bomb Buckingham Palace
and here's a picture just afterwards of
that scene now American troops were
advised that will find this this is
really interesting he warns the
anonymous writer of the advice to
American servicemen coming to Britain
which was handed out a Psychlo
stylesheets being repackaged can find it
on on on the net it's being sold now and
read he says the English the British
people this is 940 to the British people
have great affection for their monarch
but they have stripped him practically
of all political power jazz well to
remember this in your comings and goings
about England but be careful be careful
not to criticize the King British feel
about him the way you would feel if
anyone spoke against our country or our
flag today's king
Queen stuck with the people through the
blitzes and had their home bombed like
anyone else and people are proud of this
so the idea of some besieged figure
Imperial figure now as you know some of
the most interesting works neo-romantic
works are those commissioned broke of
commission brokered by kenneth clarke
with the royal family to depict windsor
castle and windsor is seen almost as a
as an opera stage set it's a particular
kind of romantic fiction I'm going to
speed up I can see here now I called
this airstrip on this talk because the
george orwell noticed that american
servicemen and particularly flyers from
the Eighth Army Air Force referred to
England as airstrip warm and we know
that he then folds that into the
narrative in 1984 the whole country
becomes is no longer the United Kingdom
it is airstrip one and the view of the
enormous revolution in meaning that
comes about through aerial views and I
show you this by someone you may not be
familiar with this is alain soral who
was a reconstructive artist who helped
the Ministry of Works imagine how
buildings that they had to take care of
you know ruins of monasteries ruined
churches Bronze Age monuments how might
they have looked so he's probably like
Cornish a dual time scale to him and his
his painting of a watercolor of of the
avro anson flying over a break in the
cloud and I was reminded of
wh auden's prophetic well not prophetic
it's a poem from 1930 called consider
this in in our time and this is called a
cabin in the clouds and Auden says as
the hawk sees it or the helmeted airmen
the clouds rift suddenly look there on
the border a smoldering cigarette end so
elsewhere this this imaginary point of
view has been called a global
information optic that you have this
suddenly this overwhelming mastery of
view and but granted as if by magic and
in the theater like that backdrop of
Windsor Castle suddenly it's revealed to
is in a coup d'etat true we have to
mention this I have misgivings about
this Kassius has misgivings about this
this is for Nash's gigantic history
painting the Battle of Britain there's
many things we could say about this one
is of course that Nash is putting
together aspects of public made public
information photographs drawing drawings
RAF material so that if you look at the
extreme how do you do this well just go
right in the and you'll see a formation
of Nazi bombers coming through and he
appropriates it from this from the
official her majesty's stationery office
booklet called the Battle of Britain so
this piece of graphic art winds up in
that extraordinary painting the Battle
of Britain
here's the bachelor is the front and
back cover of that publication and this
is where I have to say something about
Kenneth Clarke's view of English weather
Nash and many people were hypnotized by
the contrails of the fighting aeroplanes
the dogfights and there is a lively
correspondence in the press about what
was what was causing this these these
cloudy trails that that produce a kind
of automatic writing in the sky I mean
Virginia Woolf had been here before when
she describes a sign writing air
aircraft flying over London spelling out
somebody's name but a sign in the skies
now for Kenneth Clark lyrical cloud
escapes were very important let me read
you something he said he gave a BBC
radio broadcast in April 941 that that
is one of the great treasures of English
Romantic writing it's an extraordinary
piece he was congratulated immediately
afterwards by many of the artists for
for putting this on the radio you know
I've got god knows how many millions
heard this or maybe they turned off when
they heard Clark's accent I don't know
he said he put together a contrast
between the freedom-loving English and
continental totalitarians his a quote
he's talking about ways of seeing
modernist arts way of seeing and a kind
of contemporary continental optic
conditioned by totalitarianism
contrasted with lyrical visions of
broken weather changing
that the English are lucky enough to
have been gifted by Almighty God quote
the atmosphere is quite different on the
continent but people there do literally
see things in a different light a hard
steady and unchanging light which allows
them to develop hard steady unchanging
hatreds so tough luck on French
classicism there it's and this is how he
sets up a kind of Manichean dualism
which he'd already developed with Harold
Nicolson thinking about the bloomsbury
set in a special issue of picture post
during the the the fear of invasion
crisis in the summer of nineteen forty
in which they laid out a whole issue of
picture post with contrast between the
Nazi way of life and the English Way of
life on the one hand we have beautiful
cloud escapes than that's as well you
know they have lines of steel armored
vehicles and things I just offer you
this because then it was turned into an
exhibition for the National Book League
and on the one hand we've got a Nazi
soldier admiring the vermox handiwork
and below him crucially the literature
which nazi germany has and it only has
one kind of literature mine camp i don't
know if that's visible to you there
below that photograph photos so it's a
very interesting for magic and shipped
propaganda that the Clark and Harold
Nichols have put together on the other
hand this wonderful asymptomatic image
of an RAF pilot he's seated underneath a
Lysander it was an RAF artillery liaison
plane used a lot during the Battle of
France and what's the pilot doing he's
sitting down and he's reading and he's
looking he may be reading some flight
manual I
no idea of going through papers but but
below him are a kind of medley of
English novels English poetry and so
that dualism I won't labor the point now
we think a lot about anymore and the
tube we think a lot about Henry Moore
and his records of the shelters in the
london underground system and Bill
Brandt's wonderful photographs of that
but it's an art if you like it's a form
of visual culture which is produced
against the background of an enormous
panic on the part of the authorities the
war artists Advisory Committee a body
shadowy body called home intelligence
which was partly staffed by mass
observation which had to report to
Churchill every day a document about the
morale of the English people but
specifically during the bombing campaign
during the Blitz on that the fear was
that people would panic or maybe would
just never come to the surface again
they'd be like troglodytes and they stay
underground or worse still the contagion
that that epidemics would break out so a
battery of medical experts immunologists
it's a very interesting that the number
of disciplines and discourses that there
are producing the more and brant
photographs we go oh and are and we look
at the beautiful at the beautiful
photograph but it comes out of a very it
is a crisis and enormous crisis what the
hell is going to happen we'll about
these shelters this is picture post and
proposed to be agitating for proper
medical supervision of what was
occurring below the city streets of
London now bill brandt is recruited to
make a record of what's going on and one
of the things he's directed towards and
henry moore have been directed towards
this please record the medical situation
amor said no no thanks oh I won't do
that I won't go to the / first aid post
I'll just draw the people i have another
motif here and brant however was
directed show the sanitary conditions
these the ones you don't see but the
overflow of sewage the very rudimentary
toilet arrangements the buckets I won't
go into this anymore but you get the
picture I hope and and if you like the
lead the piloting agency and all this is
picture post and a photograph like this
which you see the caption life is very
public now a mother caring for this
child and more uses this as a motif so
more builds up a counter-narrative not
of dependency upon ready-made materials
but of his existential encounter one day
when the cheap one night when that you
train the doors open and there is this
vast spectacle of abject humanity in
front of him everybody knew about that
but also everybody read picture post and
so did Henry well brands photographs
were judged to be so important that they
were given to Wendell Willkie is over
just after days failure to become
president he sent by roosevelt on an
important mission to report on
conditions in in england and
particularly in london and particularly
the conditions of blitz sheltering and
he is actually given an album of
photographs by brand which then he gives
to roosevelt and there in the roosevelt
library
now that's only one little element in
the whole battery of how discourse
around the idea of the plight of Britain
and the Blitz and we'll go on to think
about ed the radio American radio
reporters but that traffic between
building up a case for being generous
and lending the English selling the
English war material and and his ed
Murrow in many ways the the reporting
particularly the Blitz the
representation of blitz is an
anglo-american artifact because the most
you know a great vast bulk of it are the
live broadcast of egg morrow and others
other American reporters reporting on
the bombing firsthand standing on roofs
in London and there's the sounds off and
they are terrifying sounds and this as
far as we can see added an extraordinary
fate on the American radio listening
public well so America as Churchill
knows that America has to be we have to
is it was some Mr Blair the recent prime
minister who advised our ambassador in
in the wake of the 2001 air raids
advised our ambassador in Washington to
get so far up the ass of President Bush
that we are at one with him and I think
although churchie would never have used
those graphic terms nevertheless we had
to be at Warren in terms of generating
understanding and sympathy and here's an
example of this and those of you have
children will know what we're looking at
these are gremlins
and this is Walt Disney with flight
left-tenant Roald Dahl the children's
story writer and the year is 1942-43 and
the idea is it is that the British
information service another another
formidable shadowy organization that
acted as a kind of propaganda arm in
America saw this as a way in you you
take illustrious fighter pilots English
RAF pilots you shunt them over to
America if they're gifted as as all
three people i'll mention our as writers
see what they can do in co-productions i
mean that's what that's what the British
film industry is left with is powe
production co-production with usually
American Finance so this is Rho our down
with Walt Disney and there's his book
and this is the original this is the
design this is a real design for his
story gremlins the gremlin was a way in
which the RAF pilots could talk about
mechanical malfunctions it's the
gremlins and he turned it into a
children's story this idea of comic
grotesque comic a grotesque comic
culture this is edward borough we
thought about skulls yesterday in a very
part of a very interesting paper but
this is borough with a with a British
soldier in the skull inside his teen
helmet and that kind of grotesque is
very much a part of France were here
here are his shelter pictures and
they're full of kind of not sure what to
call it as a kind of black comedy the
old guy bottom bottom left who's
sheltering this is the crypt of a church
and he's sheltering in a stone coffin so
here's our English black romantic humor
that was so important for French
modernism you may know our
the British information service were
extremely adept in planting new stories
and photographs sesa beaten is an
exemplary figure anglo-american figure
who commuted until a disgraceful
anti-semitic episode in his career in
1938 had had regularly been seen as part
of the American scene as a photographer
however he got life to overlook this
this route the event in the recent past
and because the picture was so poignant
and so sentimentally mobilizing she's
called Eileen done the different
accounts of this don't tally because in
one account from the Ministry of
Information she's a Yorkshire lass in
others she's she's a London girl and
anyway the point is that innocence and
childhood has been attacked and there it
is on the front of Life magazine now
again somebody I've met whose name I've
mentioned they say bram game games who
who work for the army bureau of current
affairs apka and also the War Office as
opposed to designer and this became a
celebrated incident as celebrated as
Churchill's fury at powell and
pressburger I'm having an aphasic moment
the wonderful color film I've not sorry
thank you very much so Churchill could
intervene and try and censor things and
he he censored this there are only two
or three copies of this poster the
backstory is the army bureau of current
affairs wanted to to give an ideal this
is this will be your future your Britain
fight for it now this is a being
addressed to primarily to soldiers
rather than to civilians
and they did this through juxtaposing
the wretchedness of the Depression years
which we see in the back lot there in
the in this ruined house with a child
with with Ricky's suffering from this
stunted bone disease and at the front
the Finsbury health center now Finsbury
Park in terms of the social geography of
London where this was this was a kind of
vision of Hygiene and light which have
been dropped into the most one of the
most deprived areas in London it's the
place that Don McCullin came out of
where people slept six to a room and his
father died of tuberculosis in that room
so here is a vision of the future you
will be safe and it will overcome this
horror that you see in the background
and there is a brown games on the great
unsung heroes he then migrated to Israel
he was a convinced Zionist and games
works with and otto neurath no wrath was
part of the vienna circle quite close to
vic and stein and who came to england in
the 1930s as a refugee with a novel
scheme he'd been developing of turning
statistics and social surveys into
pictographs this is called the isotype
method and I've just chosen this because
it seems fitting in terms of this
conference here is this turning of
statistics into graspable images and
here's another very succinct
hieroglyphic isotype image from it's a
book called something like only the
Atlantic stands between and you see a
schematic outline of London on the right
and Manhattan on the left with an
aeroplane transiting over the pond if
you like origin of Thames and Hudson
brand name again Viennese refugees the
Thames and the Hudson so very very
suggestive image games did three of
these diagrams which use the kind of
surrealist rhetoric of well you don't
need me to tell you that I should say
something about this picture why it was
banned Ernie Bevin who was a trade union
leader part of Churchill's having it
found himself at he had to go to a
reception at Harrods and Harrods was
hosting a pop-up exhibition from the
Army Bureau of current affairs and there
were its new posters being laid out for
the first time on the walls Bevin was
apoplectic you is this are we to show
this spectacle of abjection again is
this what we want went back to Churchill
and Churchill said it is a disgraceful
about this picture it is a disgraceful
libel on the conditions prevailing in
Great Britain before the war i order
them to be pulped so all of all the
posters for this were destroyed apart
from one or two now I mentioned pop-up
exhibitions do you have that term in
America the pop-up exhibition so places
like underground tube stations overnight
the men from the ministry of information
will be there with we talked a little
bit about in exhibition installations in
terms of planning and
and put these visions of modernity
encouraging visions in the actual form
of the exhibition itself and I love this
image because here is a genuine East End
proletarian how do I know that he's got
a particular kind of knotted scarf you
know like Dick Van Dyke wears in Mary
Poppins he's got one right as Nick like
this and he's got his son with him and
they are in there looking at the future
the future is beckoning from this from
this exhibition it's called london pride
the exhibition which was a popular song
you had to figure the way in which there
could be a movement with mobilisation of
labour from civilian life and civilian
appearance to that of being the worker
citizen who has been absorbed into a
complex industrial system this is Ted
McKnight kalfa who is an American who
had worked in London for years in that
from the 1920s 30s and helped during the
war to produce designs for this end so
here's a lady who's reporting for labor
and soon her civilian clothes will be
gone and she'll use the air pump you see
her other self there and similarly this
businessman who's already got his
standard issue lee-enfield rifle over
his arm and his gas mask will shortly
become a real soldier this this was time
and time again these contrasts talked
about contrast and bill brandt picture
which is still extremely striking called
doing the Lambeth walk the young lady on
the Left in picture post in 1943 at the
moment of the maximum mobilisation of
labor why the Nazis lost the war because
they never early enough on
mobilized all their productive capacity
now I'm being given a signal that and
I'll just end on the the contrast
between those two images between in
another context people speak very
affirmative Lee about the young lady on
the Left a cheerful proletarian but here
she's being shown as somebody who is on
the streets and she's not in the youth
club what's she doing on the other hand
this young woman today youth has plenty
to do the girls Training Corps gives her
skill training a neat uniform and a
purposeful air and of course that's the
rhetoric that all well picks up on in
1984 you remember that Julia can't say
she's the heroine but Julia where's the
sash of the anti-sex League she's
already been enrolled into the world of
of fully mobilized co-ordinated labor
well I I've hardly got through anything
that I wanted to show you your questions
on America answered here this is one of
the pop-up exhibitions beautiful drawing
for a version of it this I find the most
extraordinary graphic this is this is
bridging the Atlantic his Monroe wheeler
and again i apologize for a shockingly
pixelated image she's showing how
america will coordinate and dominate the
airways in the future this is barley
still at mama it's an exhibition he was
working on kent and and here's the
exhibition britain at war and here it is
using images from england's imperial
past from the defeat of the dutch navy
at the end of the 70th century in the
world what are we doing there we are
just say one more word because there's
an image i would really do want to show
you about this young man we've talked
about Roald Dahl as a RAF pilot going to
America here's another young man who was
sent to America
as propaganda this is Richard Hillary
the author of the last enemy an
extraordinary figure if you've never
read the novel it's it's the first
English existentialist novel published
in 43 44 just before his death and here
he is drawn by Eric kennington it's a
kind of Holbein esque chalk drawing
fabulous he's one of the long haired
boys had they called the fighter pilots
you see is a long hair there and
kennington have been so affected by his
friendship with Richard Hillary the when
Hillary's finally shot down he'd already
been shot down and received hideous
burns which had been fixed by plastic
surgery and so on so on and kennington
produced this picture of the spectral
form of Richard Hillary rising out of
the North Sea you had that kind of
global perspective in the in the
wonderful Battle of Britain picture by
for Nash and here he is and this puts
his in mind of course of the those trip
tix we were looking at yesterday you
know the ongoing value of supernatural
figures in this case it's secularized
supernatural I don't think I need to
explain it I think it's so so so
extraordinary and so touching well
that's it that's your lot as English
comics radio comics are that's
interesting this is another one of
Harold Nicolson and Kenneth Clarke's
attempts to mobilize English literature
english what are we really fighting for
turns out its words with and Shakespeare
that we're really fighting for and this
running caption from Wordsworth some it
is not to be thought of poem of of 1806
we must be free or die who speak the
tongue that Shakespeare's fake and again
that series of opposition's between
totalitarian visions particularly that
display in the middle where we see a
Nuremberg rally juxtaposed with a
English pastoral idyll where cricket is
being played and it goes on like that
that's it that is your lot forgive me
for holding you up for so long sorry